well I've been to actually some very
lavish parties and actually when you
talk about lavish parties it becomes
sort of what your experience of parties
are because I've been to so many parties
they'll probably been to a thousand
parties or more in my life and lots of
them were the result of lavish
expenditure and you know I've been to
parties at Versailles which Versailles
itself is so lavish that any party there
would be lavish in America the most
remarkably lavish party that I have ever
attended and it was attended at a time
in my life when I hadn't had as much
experience going to party so it was new
for me was in Beverly Hills I was it was
a holiday party a Christmas party given
by a couple named Barbara and Marvin
Davis and they used to give a very very
big holiday party this is in the late
1980s they lived in a very very grand
house they had very grand entertainment
they had Santa and mrs. Claus and all
the elves and the reindeers there they
served the best champagne the house was
enormous and it was full of very famous
faces so many famous faces I can't even
remember them all the dinner tables were
of ten or twelve were surrounded by very
famous people and it wasn't said it and
the party itself was set in a very very
large tent behind their very very large
house and to me that was just absolutely
end in lavishness Oh golly um I don't
know I don't not answer that question um
I don't know what to say to I I do so
much of what I do by going to parties
and meeting a lot of people but a lot of
it is be almost routine and I don't mean
to make it sound as if it's dull or
boring because it's not dull or boring
but as terms of a favorite moment is
concerned it usually has something to do
with other people
talents and that talent might be
listening to somebody very very
brilliant speaking or listening to
somebody who is very talented singing or
playing or are seeing people get very
excited about raising a great deal of
money that definitely will have an
impact for example in New York that's
the Central Park Conservancy and these
people mainly women who put together the
Conservancy have had a huge impact in
making central park and other parks
really wonderful places for us in the
metropolis to go and have some respite
from from city life and I think those
are really wonderful things those things
really turn me on